you know one of the knee-jerk reactions
whenever a camera ends up
catching a professional athlete or an
athlete at any level is the
high mom and since yesterday was
mother's day
today's draft is the best mugging for
the camera moment specifically
player comments that we will always
remember made into a camera any place
anytime anywhere chris
trivia question that i just thought of
that i know you will appreciate
in which state of the united states of
america
did mother's day originate oh what
state i didn't know this so this
originated in a state
okay um
where would is there no logic to this at
all is it totally
like is there anything a little logic
too little logical logic
yeah a little bit a little bit okay all
right i'm going to say new jersey since
i'm from new jersey
yeah right idea wrong state that's
connected virginia
i should have known it comes back to you
of course it did come back
i was giving you a clue well wait a
minute that's the one fact that i know
about mother's day anna jarvis started
mother's day in 1907 within five years
every state was recognizing mother's day
so yes
just up the road i think it was in
grafton west virginia anna jarvis
started mother's day so uh i tried i
tried i tried yeah that's all right i
like it that was good that was it was
plus
personal right church wrong pew good
good i liked it
all right uh you know the first one for
me
even though it didn't happen anywhere
close to a field
yeah it it's got to be
and and there are like three or four
different items
from it we will always be known as the
straight cash homie
moment from randy moss let's go ahead
and see how much of it we could
really and truly appreciate after he was
after he was fined
for pretending to moon the crowd at
lambeau field
he was chased to his truck by reporters
and he gave one of the all-time great
nfl player sound bites
you don't write chicks
how do you pay man if you don't write
checks how do you pay these guys
great cash homie
were you upset about the fight no
because ain't number 10
[Applause]
that's 10 grand
there's more there's more go to youtube
there's more
oh you want you like that last that last
second i like what he says at the end
i like what he says he's gonna do the
next time
youtube.com that's my pick i'm gonna
shut up you're up
yup that's a good one though i do like
that a whole lot uh
of course you went to the vikings good
and randy randy's hilarious like
he really is i i just being around him a
little bit in my career
i could totally see him pulling off that
moment all right
for me you know one of the the one that
always jumps out to my brain more than
any
right just as far as like when i was
growing up
the shannon sharp on the sidelines
in foxborough against the patriots
call the national guard because the
patriots need
help we are what does he say we're we're
killing them killing the people killing
the patriots
send the national guard all of that i
mean that to me
was like an unbelievable moment and i
think what also
like makes it better was what happened
let's see that year
let's see that was the year the broncos
what lost in the
to jacksonville right in the divisional
playoff game upsetting they were the
best team in the league that year uh but
that that's a pretty awesome moment by
shannon sharp
yeah that was at the old patriots
stadium and he's having fun as they were
kicking the crap out of the patriots
that day and yes they got stunned by the
jaguars but then won
the next two in a row i like that one i
like that one i like that
and that's where i'm going next damn
minnesota all over here
he was playing for washington and that
squeaky peter brady time to change voice
coming off the field do we have
here we go you can hear it again for
yourself kirk cousins
we like that you like that you like that
you like that i love it what a psycho
awesome uh yeah that was personal yeah
you know that was like really getting
some demons he tried
he tried something like an ue at one
point too but the yeah you like that uh
you you like that as number one ue is a
far number two for kirk cousins no that
was
that was pretty damn special i mean that
was a pretty cool moment
uh by kirk cousins he's not the kind of
guy that shows that type of emotion
or yells at a camera or does that type
of stuff uh but that was a crucial part
of his career he made it
what was that like a last-second
touchdown pass against the bucks right
and some game there and then uh you like
that
ended up too yeah you like that you love
me i'm on your team
the minnesota vikings
all right my next one here and i don't
know if we're gonna have b-roll of this
one because this is an old nfl films
classic here
right but you'll know this one anybody
that's watched nfl films or anything
like lawrence taylor on the sideline
of a 1984 preseason game you know the
one where he's
it's going down like a bunch of crazed
dogs have some fun
you know and then he's they got him
miked up and he's tackling kenny o'brien
he's going son
y'all got to do better than this like
all those moments like a psycho on the
sidelines
that was my even though my dad played
for the team that was my first
experience of knowing that my dad's
teammate was a psycho
i can still remember being a young kid
like who is this guy
56 is amazing and he yells and does all
that stuff
but just like the personality of
lawrence taylor and going off on the
sideline to me is one of those great
high mom moments
and that was a preseason game that was a
priest when he said that we got like a
pack of crazed dogs
pre-season game against the jets right
that's how crazy lawrence taylor is
so there was a point where the giants
took that game as seriously as the jets
once did remember when rex ryan put mark
sanchez back in the game and got him
injured because they had to have
that snoopy trophy i know yes oh and
back in that day like
those are some of my dad's best war
stories is like that preseason game
number three against the jets he hated
it
because he was like oh man mark
gastineau and that defense
and it was the first live like let's
have a real game type of moment
and uh i think dad's got a few battle
scores on his body from some of those
preseason games still
or battle scars scores speaking of the
jets
they know who we mean bart scott talking
to sal palantonio after a playoff win
getting ready to take on the patriots
back in 2010 a game that the jets would
win
can't wait was bart scott i can't wait
there it is can't wait
can't wait can't wait sounds like that's
it there's more you're leaving that's it
that's good that's enough can't wait
awesome can't wait let's see was that
the year
they went to the colts or did they go to
the is that
that was after they beat the pace
steelers that was exactly they beat
the yeah yeah can't wait can't wait it
would
help if i properly knew the context of
one of my all-time great quotes it was
after they beat the patriots
yeah then they went then they went to uh
yeah they uh
beat the colts and peyton manning beat
brady and then they couldn't beat big
ben and company in the the afc
championship game um all right i'm the
last one i mean i'm going
to a special moment in the sims family
history i mean yes
i mean you're talking about high mom
moments and my dad did
you know i'm going to disney world he
was the first guy ever to do that
i'm gonna go disney world look there i
am i'm at disney world look at that
look at that hey mom i want to cut the
line and go on space mountain the hell
with all these people i want to cut
the blocks which one is you the blonde
on the bottom the blonde yeah the one
that looks like
phil's kid he's my cousin josh yeah he's
older than me he's my cousin josh
yep but those are the good i think that
was disneyland
uh at this point right here that we
ended up going to but
yeah pretty awesome big phil got a big
paycheck for that i don't know what he
got paid but
uh it was pretty awesome moment in our
life at least do you remember what rides
what rides did you go on uh i mean at
that i i think like you know what is it
not splash uh the thunder mountain right
that was like
thunder mountain and space mountain when
i was that age i mean come on that was
as cool as it got i
i was a little too old for just like
like mickey mouse going in a circle or
something like that so i don't know i
picture you on the tea cups
i picture you on the tea cups and then
stump you on somebody
[Laughter]
hey mom and then cursing them out for
getting in the way of your uh
never mind all right let's take a break
we'll wrap up this monday edition pft
library happens
oh my gosh that's crazy
look at dirty diana
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports